au delà ce qu'elles ont bien travaillé
aujourd'hui en avec ian sur over rouge
salut yan tu es une voix sensuelle jan
alors c'est parti sous-entendez gardons
micro c'est normal on voit pas faire
genre il est juste dans la pièce d'à
côté
celui ci a au moins tous les jours dans
le salon de squeeze alors aujourd'hui on
joue au nouveau jeu de blizzard il est
en bêta ouverte jusqu'à dimanche soir
liana aujourd'hui on va jouer le sarge
winston alors déjà on commence une game
est un mec me dit squeeze tu pue ça
m'est vraiment confiance pour cette
partie à laurianne ton téléphone est à
côté de moi et tu as un message de ta
puce
ah merde
aujourd'hui on enquête sur la livrée de
yann non ça ne suit pas ça m'a donné des
gages et gaujac zellers est lui attendu
mais attend et on va voir des photos de
tous ici pense que c'est comme ça oui
allez on connaît bien gâteau sur google
images on connaît bien on est sur un
mode de jeu on doit contrôler le même
point allez c'est parti
royal kate ou devant avait séché dessus
non je t'attends tu t'attends du tpr et
yann et là on va sauter à 3 3 je suis en
train de suivre un ange
j'ai tué un ange projet souffre et je
leur en fils avait deux fois je le tue
le solde en lui courant sont sur le
point tueries sont en train de le
prendre il faut qu'on aille à 100%
oh là là là là alors qu'il a plus de vie
vas-y aulas lors la prière pour leurs
prix dans le courageux et en plus y'a
pas que l'électricité dans le g fait
rater ma blague
al.yahia pas que l'électricité statique
dans notre gueule voilà que ça pour une
blague nuls on glisse on prendra ce
point coûte que coûte c'est la guerre
des territoires c'est la guerre des
mondes on le laissera brian may hamm
ah ben on est bien ils sont à 99 km à
l'est surtout pas qu'il y aller on est
baisé ils ont pris un gorille et nous
complétons patronale it et non ses 99e
cape rouge et sans projet surtout soyez
surtout se dégager du temps l'histoire
dégager de croix ok tu fais quoi tu vas
mourir soit gelée suivi j'ai lu yan à et
les à l'aise on ne le font pas on a
gagné ou pas j'ai pas vu je je sais pas
oui ok y est c'est parti là tu fais quoi
tu sautes dans le trou yan tu le mets
comme dans le lit j'ai raté le trovan à
7 arrive souvent
ah ben je tombais sur sud à côté des
parents alors il ya lui va se calmer
direct mon gars aller à l'électricité
statique dans tes cheveux ça colle au
ballon de baudruche
c'est vrai ou pas sur le point où est
sur le point là je me fais défoncer par
tout le monde a hâte est sur le point de
se faire défoncer ouais c'est waou
allez je suis mort ok attends-moi
terrain winston ouais tout est ok ok
attends moi oh oh non ils ont eu un yann
pour cette troisième manche qui est
finalement la belle on va tous les deux
joué
google n'a rien on est trop avec des
lance grenades s'est vraiment l'anti jeu
le plus total et les empêchent d'aller
un max de grenade
l'anti jeu le plus total yade allez je
mets une petite bombe pour aller plus
vite je passe au dessus du truc arrivée
style et puis j'ai trouvé bien évident
qu les gens voient des créatures les
noisettes dedans
je vais jouer comme on dit là mais jerry
de over ou h
elle s'appelle très seraient peut se
téléporter prennent pas beaucoup de
villes entre soeurs non elle a pas
beaucoup dit parce qu'en fait elle se
déplace très très vite tu vois tu
t'approches étudiants sur un mec tu
téléporte il voit plus et tu le termine
ils sont ils sont neuf toiles dans le
vide
ouais j'ai remonté dans le temps du coup
si on monte sur la plateforme média le
manque de génie et ckoi l'ultime trailer
du titre et soeurs elles posent une
bombe qui fait très très mal tu vois en
1 89% ils ont repris le point allons
nous gagner yann tout le monde se pose
cette [ __ ] de questions tiens par de
maire juif agf arabe
ok j'en ai que j'en ai deux je me casse
la gueule je retourne sur le point je
tire sur l'agresseur j'ai la très sûr je
lance une bombe et le dernier au lycée
gagner c'est gagné
et voilà il ya aucun de nous deux sur le
tableau des gens fort pour qu'on y
serait aucune idée tu as eu des
médailles de quoi aux jets médaille d'or
mais quand où j'ai pas envie de le dire
ne faut pas voir au tchad on est tous
passés par la médaille en chocolat
si selon ce que du chocolat alors là
changement monial
en gros les aînés doivent escorter un
vaisseau jusqu'à notre base et dont
doigt mais on doit les empêcher
d'escorté sauver son jus tous les deux
des cowboys walhalla alors j'ai vraiment
un perso tu spam les clic droit et ça
tue les gens affamés fois encore visés
voilà à l'équipe on y retourne alors
aulas l'a bien dit zhao 6 l'appel genji
page irak un package irak
excellent abusent ils envoient les
shuriken attention à l'utile et cowboys
lüthi des cow boys étape une pression de
la touche sur le coeur ça a marché
oui ça marche on a tué le tour n'a tué
un [ __ ] ggf car pitcho l'attentât fait
l'autre
et la mecque la danse au jules si je dis
oui ça verrouillé en revanche j'en ai
bien j'en ai deux j'en ai eu trois yo ma
et le groupe caillé j'en ai eu quatre
mois plus tard à nous je suis fière au
nom en haut en bas c'est la mort là la
seule à bord on est tous morts il ya le
regard c'est pas grave viennent c'est
pourquoi parce qu'on est des cow boys
devrait aux [ __ ] j'ai la carte j'ai
six pouces verts 7 pouces verts
n'hésitez pas à liker la carte
ah merde on va être des mister freeze
yan tu vas prendre mais mettez sur je
savais qu'ils allaient faire un jeu de
mots layan note perso en fait quand tu
tire sur l'ennemi ça va être gelé ou
d'un moment je ne bouderai un bonhomme
de gouverne je me suis bloqué l'europe à
l'honneur ce soir ça va en quoi tresseur
on va john est très seraient ce que tu
aimes avoir le cul jolie annacone
les livrer
je ne mendie les plus âgés j'ai beaucoup
d'intérêt nous sommes patriote nous
sommes français l'armée de france
débarque au verbe au chc débarquement
vas-y je te suis pas de voir yann gorge
locaux yann hamon signal on va sortir
comme ça et on lâche tout ce qu'on a tu
entend la marseillaise qui arrive oui je
l'entends j'entends bien marquer
yann je vais à l'état je met mon ultime
stabilise l'étape automatiquement le
cheat c'est parti
ok merde j'ai plus le pti cette fois
yann on perdra pas on se laissera pas
abattre par ces sauvageons qui veulent
voler nos terres c'est notre base yann
on défendra cette patrie je suis mort
bien ce département et sur le plancher
en temps
c'est perdu chez rien compris en tant
que vengeance je vais jouer ce qu'on
appelle un gros porc et toi tu vas jouer
un ange
donc en fait on si une armistice mais on
va quand même les attaquer c'est
exactement ça toi tu viens et tu perds
ta gueule je connais bien les quais en
escorte ont des scores aulas l'a regardé
cette percée compagne anne c'est d'une
beauté
j'avoue que là on perçoit bien à laon et
spéciaux par bosch charge peux tu nous
dire
en bas dans tous deux
j'arrive vers toi mon petit ange pour
revient vers soins oui je suis belle
non content c'est du caca
j'ai empêché l'eau de matthew si c'était
super bien on voit croyait la banque
royale et c'est mon père il a tout tué
le texte dit ok du show il est mort on
est bon on est bon allez allez allez
il ya très certainement à tresserre elle
fait reculer le lmj vaisseau d'avancé en
tournant autour des soucis aux [ __ ]
commandes à plus de balagne à l'oreille
arriver c'est le dernier poste c'est le
poche de l'espoir à gogo ce matin
annonce maintenant c'est passé
maintenant c'est manon rien c'est le
plus à l'aise mois ces deux plats chauds
seront âgées mourir trop culture c'est à
ultima d'état allez-vous escorte les
vaisseaux je suis mort oui c'est besson
fait
sauf quand même pas grand chose malgré
tout tu as un maître il a dû là mais je
suis ça c'est non seulement c'est
variable serait sur le point pour
histoire de mes gars soient ya des
coteaux [ __ ] mais c'est pas possible
au nom de m arrivé à l'est à un maître
paul assez le total des coûts et on
n'est même pas aussi 69 % du temps passé
à déchirer
tous les jours sauf que voilà juste la
fin de cette vidéo sur over the mercian
m'avoir supporte d'enseignés de m'avoir
supporté tout court d'ailleurs
non mais moi ça me fait très plaisir
n'hésitez pas bientôt ça vous appelez je
vous propose une petite ouverture de
coffre
parce que win over outre on gagne des
coffres quand on passe des nobel il peut
y avoir un item légendaire dedans là par
exemple n'y a rien de légendaires mais
j'en ai un deuxième dans lequel ya rien
de légionnaires s'était l'epic fail à
13,2 prochaine vu porter ou bien tu
n'étais pas allé par la chaîne de yann
barthès bien jacques beaume pis